pesée des vélos échauffement ce jeudi
soir la coupe du monde de cyclisme a
débuté avec les qualifications de
poursuites et de vitesse par équipes
ça revêt une importance considérable
dans la mesure où
les gens viennent chercher des points
pour se qualifier pour les championnats
du monde et c'est la première épreuve
qui est qualificatif pour les jeux
olympiques donc une grande importance
pour toutes les nations présentes ici
plus de 350 athlètes sont engagés pour
cette première manche de coupe du monde
parmi les 52 pays représentés de grandes
nations comme les anglais les néo
zélandais et les australiens et la
france on se sent bien l'heure actuelle
l'équipe de france a bien travaillé ces
dernières semaines on a des conditions
ici au niveau du vélodrome
des bonnes conditions climatiques ce
même si on est sur un vélodrome couvert
c'est important pour nous il faut savoir
que la pression atmosphérique qui joue
beaucoup sur les performances
il fait très chaud
il le bois est très sec qu'à l'heure
actuelle c'est important pour nous de
bien débuter on à domicile donc il faut
qu'on arrive à valider un certain nombre
de résultats pour se mettre dans le
confort les tricolores espère bien
briller sur cette compétition la récente
championne d'europe de queyries mathilde
gros 19 ans part favorite sur cette
épreuve